hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the strong points of this article
corporate governance and ethics of
feminist perspective is that it focuses
on the issue of caring as Central to
feminist ethics and also something that
can come out of other ethics as well
including conscient and and rawlsian
approaches now care is a term that
sounds really good it's really easy to
use it's easy to talk about you know
being caring or being empathetic and so
long as we remain at a high level of
generality there don't seem to be too
many problems with it except for people
who think that we ought to be uncaring
but the question you might ask is well
how does this actually play itself out
within a business ethics context when we
start getting to not absolute
specificity of you know individual cases
but sort of that middle level where the
concepts need to to apply in general
ways then you know there there are some
some confusions and perhaps some places
where somebody might say I'm not sure
exactly how this applies so one of the
good points that's made by the art the
article and its authors is that there's
a lot of discussions at the time that
they're writing about who to care for
so there's a lot of discussion for
example about stakeholders and
identifying who the stakeholders are and
thinking about which ones are
particularly vulnerable you know for
example if you're if you're thinking
about a customer base not all customers
are exactly the same and some might
require a kind of Duty or imperative of
care more than others you know for
example if you're marketing to both
adult segments and children the children
would need to be attended to somewhat
differently you might not Orient your
advertising in such blatant ways as to
arouse their desires if you're following
a an ethics of care
now one of the things that gets left out
unfortunately
is discussions about how to care so
there's a lot of discussion about who to
care for but not a lot of discussion
about the modalities of care that would
be involved how to care in such a way
that you're actually making the
situation better not just you know
throwing this open-ended care in there
as if you're throwing a bunch of Life
preservers out but how to actually
Empower others in the process because
the ethics of care is developmental it's
not simply about taking care of others
for the rest of their life and as
they're going to point out there's a
really great discussion of this
um the uh the ethical caring processes
cannot simply be
ongoing and and entirely lacking
reciprocity so they say the first two
Dimensions that we're going to talk
about carrying about and taking care of
are the first steps in building an
ethics of care but they resemble to some
extent to problem-solving approach for
an ethical caring process to fully
develop the caring relation cannot be a
one-way system that might Foster
dependence on the one cared for now
there are going to be some situations
you know during childhood the the parent
is going to have to care for children in
ways that you know most likely the
children can't care back although they
can return the care later on when
there's you know uh you know aging
process taking place and perhaps
senility or something like that and
there may be some people who are
permanently cast in the position of
having to be cared for without being
able to care back or able to develop
that's rarely the case within a business
ethics context however and so if we're
talking about caring in the sense of for
example a manager who's dealing with a
quote difficult employee uh using care
rather than you know strict Justice in
doing evaluations and coaching and
things like that it's not meant to keep
that person in a dependent relationship
their entire time but rather to empower
them to be able to develop their
potential and better themselves and
perhaps even be able to Mentor somebody
down the line what are the the the side
effects or uh the bad consequences of
permanently
dependent relationships of care for the
caregiver one of the big problems is
burnout and emotional withdrawal so it's
very important that there be what they
call relational reciprocity leading to
empowerment and emancipation that won't
always happen but that is the ideal
that's governing it and so we can
distinguish uh four different dimensions
of care that all need to be part of the
process if the ethics of care is going
to be applied well
within a business context and they put
this into a useful table so the first
part of it is caring about and the focus
there is on the recognition that there
is a need to care you may identify again
an employee as somebody who needs to be
cared for in ways that are different
than the other employees you notice that
they for example may have more anxiety
in being given new assignments and so
you you know spend a little bit of extra
time walking them through that you
identify them as somebody who who's
going to need care and what are the key
values here attentiveness is one of them
being able to actually take in uh who is
going to be more vulnerable who needs
more help Focus
susceptibility being able to actually
take in somebody else's views then we
have the next level and this is where it
becomes active taking care of
so this is uh going to involve a focus
on willingness and capacity to do
something about a situation where care
is needed not everybody who recognizes
that somebody needs care will actually
respond in such a way as to say well
I guess they're not getting it I had
better be ready to provide it even if
that sets us behind a little bit on a
deadline or a task or you know maybe
might affect the bottom line in very
Marginal Way so this willingness that's
a disposition and capacity that's
another important aspect not everybody
has the capacity to either care in the
sense of being empathetic or to do
something so you know I might I might
register that somebody needs uh help but
I might not have the time to do it
because of all the other things that I'm
doing which might include caring for
other people so the key value here is
responsibility so first we have
attentiveness and then responsibility
we get to the real action part of it the
full action when we get to care giving
this is the the third dimension of care
carrying out carrying carrying out
caring activities or ensuring that
caring needs are met now notice why do
they have to put both of those things in
there because you can't do everything
yourself
imagine something outside of a business
situation you have an aged parent and
you need to to go to work what do you do
to ensure that that aged parents needs
are met well you might bring in a home
nurse or you might call a neighbor to
check in on them or there might be all
sorts of other things that you do as
well it doesn't all have to be you as
the individual providing the care could
be relying on a network to help support
that intention of caring so
what are the key values involved here
there's two really important ones and
and I I particularly like so one of them
is empathy right being able to empathize
with the other person which does not
mean feeling everything that they feel
but actually being able to register what
it is that they're feeling and
responding appropriately the second one
however is competence
it doesn't do any good to provide care
except on a very basic level if you're
not competent in some way to provide
that care so you know armchair
psychologists engaging in in all sorts
of analysis of their co-workers problem
on the basis of pop psychology books or
uh you know relying on Dr Phil's dictums
or something like that probably not a
good idea when it comes to care if
somebody really has a serious
psychological problem you refer them to
a counselor a psychologist a
psychiatrist a therapist somebody who's
actually competent to handle that right
finally care receiving it's not enough
if you want to have a full ethics of
care just to be always giving to other
people because if you do that you will
inevitably burn out sooner or later
care receiving is another important part
of this and the focus here is on the
interaction between the giver and
receiver of care so it's not just that
you help other people and then other
people help you there should eventually
be some sort of response on the part of
the person's health and and some may be
incapable of that and some may be
temporarily unable to do that or
unwilling to do that or they don't trust
enough but sooner or later there has to
be some sort of reciprocity being
established doesn't mean that it has to
be exactly the same thing coming back
and forth but there has to be something
and what does that involve as a value
responsiveness and receptiveness
there's a lot of people who are very
good at supporting others very good at
being empathetic with others and then
when others uh act that way towards them
they kind of freeze up they're not
really sure how to handle that it's
important to be able to receive care not
not only so that you can provide it but
also because you matter as well you are
also a human being within this Matrix of
relationships so this is a really great
discussion in this article about what
the these four dimensions of care would
be and how all of them are required in
order to realize the ideal of an ethics
of care particularly within business
ethics situations